네, 안녕하세요. 김수입니다. 제가
이번 시간에는 내년 상업용 부동산을
좀 전망을 해 보려고 하는데 일단
키워드를 몇 개 좀 적어 드릴게요.
우선 첫 번째로 양극하는도 심해질 것
같습니다. 그래서 지금 시기도 좀
그렇지만 팔리는데만 계약이 되고
그리고 임대가 되는 곳만 될 거
같아요. 정말 그 잘되는 건물만
앞으로 더 될 거 같고 그게 아마
내년에 좀 더 심하게 될 거
같습니다. 임대차 시장이 그렇게 좋지
않거든요. 지금 자영업자분들이 굉장히
힘든 상황이고 그와 반대로 예를
들어서 뭐 성수등 연무장길이라든지 뭐
악구정 로데오 메인이라든지 이런 데는
그래도 런던 베이그 있는 쪽 어 그쪽
부분 같은 경우에는 계속 최고가를
경신하고 [음악] 있습니다. 임차인들
들어올 사람들도 되게 많고 뭐 올해
이제 부자 보고서도 나오겠지만 작년
같은 경우에도 그 자산가들은 계속
많아지고 있어요. 아마 올해도
자산가들 비율은 되게 많아질 겁니다.
[음악] 지금 한국의 돈을 너무 많이
풀었어요. 그것 때문에 지금 환율이
높기도 하고. 근데 그 돈을 풀면
제일 먼저 수혜를 보는게 이제 자산가
분들이거든요. [음악] 트로피 성격의
아파트들이 계속 최고가 경신하고 있고
힐딩도 위치 좋은 거는 계속 최고가
경신하고 있고 그리고 지금 주식
시장이 되게 화랑이고 올해도 아마
자산가들이 더 많아질 것 같은데
그래서 그 자산가들이 좋아하는
부동산의 거래는 계속 내년에도 이어질
것이라고 저는 생각을 합니다. 그리고
금리 인한데 금리가 사실 올해 좀 더
떨어졌어야 되는데 지금 한국 금리를
내리기가 쉽지 않습니다. 그리고
최근에는 심지어 실질적인 금리는 좀
더 올랐어요. 그래서 아마 내년에는
뭐 조금 더 내릴 수는 있겠지만 근데
급폭이 크진 않을 것 같습니다. 사실
한국 경제가 워낙 좋지 않기 때문에이
금리를 갑자기 내렸다가 또 이렇게
진짜 풍선 효과처럼 어 부동산 가격이
막 급등하는 상황이 또 일어날 수
있기 때문에 보통은 미국 금리가
우리나라보다 낮았거든요. 근데 지금
역전된 상태로 계속 장기간이 이어지고
있습니다. 금리 인화 가능성이 있긴
하지만 뭐 무예전처럼 파격적으로
내리거나 그럴 거 같진 않아요.
그래서 사실이 상업용 부동산이 금리에
따라서 영향을 많이 받긴 하는데
금리가 아무래도 많이 떨어지지 않다
보니까 거래량이 막 대폭 상승하거나
그럴 거 같진 않습니다. 그리고 세
번째는 그 외국인들은 더 많아질 것
같아요. 그래서 뭐 최근에도 정말
계속 이제 외국인 관광객들이 많이
오고 있고 그리고 내년에 앞으로 더
많이 올 것 같습니다. 외국인들이
많이 오는 상권은 계속 좋아질 것
같아요. 유동 인구도 많아지고
임대료도 올라가고 빌딩 가격도 계속
올라갈 것 같습니다. 전 앞으로
외국인 관광객이 오는 대에 따라서
앞으로 빌딩 시장이 좀 많이 달라질
것 같습니다. [음악] 뭐 오래 못지
않게 어 내년에도 외국인들이 좀 많이
오지 않을까 어 이렇게 예상을
합니다. 그리고 마지막으로 주택
투자자분들이 빌딩 시장으로 또 많이
넘어올 것 같아요. 그래서 지금 주택
규제가 워낙 [음악] 심하다 보니까
주택 가격 보면은 빌딩보다 더
비싸거든요. 지금 주택 사실 배출
규제도 그렇고 기존에 부동산
투자하셨던 분들이 주택 투자하기에는
쉽지 않기 때문에 어 빌딩 시장에 또
많이 넘어올 것 같습니다. 그래서
아직까진 빌딩 규제가 주택보다 훨씬
덜하기 때문에 어 이런 [음악] 주택
투자자분들이 빌딩 시장으로 좀 많이
넘어올 것으로 좀 예상됩니다. 일단은
[음악] 지금 외국인 관광객들도 많이
오고 그리고 이제 여성분들도 많이
찾는 곳이기 때문에 뭐 올해와
비슷하게 아니면 그 이상으로 어찌
됐든 한남동은 좀 괜찮다라고 생각이
들고 그래서 강남구 내에서도 동별로
좀 차이가 날 거 같은데 청담이라든지
뭐 신사라든지 뭐 이런 쪽에 많이
밀집되어 있을 것 같고 거기다 뭐
삼성은 여전히 꾸준히 인기 있고 뭐
노년이라든지 역삼 그 더 나아가서는
대치까지 [음악] 그래도 계속 인기가
있을 것이 좀 예상이 되고 그리고
예상 밖으로 지금 외국인 관광 계획이
또 많이 오는 데가 저기 그 북촌
그쪽을 많이 가거든요. 제가 최근에도
주말에 갔는데 외국인 관광객이 진짜
많더라고요. 외국인 관광객이에 한국에
왔을 때 약간 한국스러운 동네가 뭐
강남 이런 데는 사실 물론 되게 고층
빌딩들이 많고 좀 그렇긴 하지만 북총
같은 경우에는 그 한옥이라든지 뭔가
한국의 그 새로운 느낌 그것 때문에
외국인 관광객들이 좀 많이 가거든요.
외국인 관광객들 좀 많이 오는데 또
한번 좀 지켜보면 좋지 않나? 최근에
[음악] 그 저희가 북촌에 있는 거를
하나 중계했는데 그 잔금 전에 저희가
통임대를 맞췄어요. 근데 통임대
금액이 생각보다 되게 높았습니다.
네. 그래서 그걸 저희도 보면서
아,이 정도로 관광객이 많이 오니까
이렇게 임대료 수준이 올랐구나라고 좀
많이 느끼게 되는데 어, 앞으로 좀
외국인들이 주로 어디 가는지도 한번
좀 지켜보시면 좋을 거 같아요.
[음악] 네. 그래서 오늘 좀 정리를
해 보자면 일단 양극한은 더 심해질
것 같다. 그래서 뭐 지금 전체적으로
안 좋긴 하지만 그래서 내년에
키워드도 빌딩 산다 그러면 자산가들이
좋아하는 동네 자산가들이 좋아할 만한
부동산을 유심히 보시는게 중요하고
그리고 금리 인하가 되긴 하겠지만 그
폭이 크진 않을 것 같습니다.
[음악] 네. 지금 한국 경제가 워낙
좋지 않기 때문에 그렇게 큰 폭으로
내릴 거 같진 않아서 거래량도 뭐
올해보다 폭등적으로 늘어나거나 그럴
거 같진 않아요. 그다음에 주택
투자자분들이 빌딩 시장으로 좀 많이
넘어올 것으로 예상이 됩니다. 코로나
때도 그렇고 그러니까 15억 초과
주택 규제랑 뭐 이렇게 취득세
중가라든지 이런 걸 좀 받으면서
실제로 좀 많이 넘어왔거든요.
이번에도 좀 주택 투자자분들이 빌딩
시장으로 좀 많이 넘어오지 않을까?
네. 이렇게 좀 예상을 해 봅니다.
그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요.
다음 시간에 뵙겠습니다.